so you you strike me
as like a healthy well-adjusted creative
dad like
relationships i feel like being a child
actor
breaks you know x percentage of
folks um you know let's call it
60 or whatever the number is like you
know and i'm sure you grew up with
people that
um went through a version of this um
like i
i became a public figure relatively
recently but i was already like a dad
and like fairly you know
mature so i actually now have a better
understanding as to how it messes people
up
um and i think you became famous in the
time before social media so
good on you you didn't have that
particular
um but but would love to hear about your
transitions that way
like going back to school how did you
find colombia because i went to law
school there so i know the environment
somewhat
and and my my wife went there um
undergrad
um so so you know it's like so i get
some of
um what that school's about but i'm
curious about the transition both
into college and then out of college and
and coming back to hollywood
yeah i mean a big part of quitting for
me and wanting to go to school was
was getting away from the kind of
attention that you get
with quote-unquote fame fame something
i've thought about a lot because yeah
i've been on on tv and in movies and
stuff ever since i was young
and um there's undeniably something
very seductive and attractive about it
and it's
i think it's pretty deep seated in our
biology and it makes sense if you're out
in the wild
and you're living in a tribe of animals
and everyone in your tribe knows who you
are
and has some kind of emotional
attachment to you you're probably more
likely to survive so that's attractive
you want that
and and that's i think we have just a
basic animal
attraction to that kind of attention and
fame
um to verify what you just said
i remember i was reading something where
it said that if you have primates in
captivity
they'll actually pay food to see
pictures
of higher status primates wow
i have not heard that that's incredible
i want to see that study
geez so because there was a time when
you look up and you're like oh celebrity
culture
like you know um like uh not very
uh natural but then when you see that
study you're like holy [ __ ] apparently
celebrity culture is like the most
natural thing in the world of course
it's very very natural but let's let's
be honest chimpanzees rape and murder
each other all day long
in the wild you know there's a lot of
things that are natural that
we oh yeah i'm not saying it's a good
thing but it is hardwired into us
it is it's hardwired into us and like
there's a lot of those things that are
hardwired into us that part of what like
being a human is about is figuring out
like how much am i going to
be swayed by this this primal monkey
instinct
to you know to act on these
urges and that yeah there is an urge
to to want to be famous and i've i've
felt it i'm drawn to it i
it's something i'd probably struggle
with to be honest like on a daily basis
how much does this matter to me how much
should it sway my decisions you know
and uh how much can i be happy without
it
it's it's hard it's it sounds funny to
say it's hard because it's a real
privilege to have
to have it but it'll mess people up
quick it really does mess people up and
i've
uh it it's i i'm not above saying like
it's probably messed me up to some
degree i do my best to have it not mess
me up too much i've seen it mess other
people up
way worse um for a lot of reasons and
and it's part of what is actually
makes me really concerned about the way
that online culture
is moving right now which is just and
look there's something really wonderful
about kind of
democratizing fame i think that in a way
that's great fame like something like
that shouldn't be limited to
just hollywood and or other like
you know super affluent metropolises
throughout you know the world
it it it should be like that i i
should be at more accessible to
everybody and and the internet
allows for that accessibility
but what it also does is it
it brings those kinds of struggles and
that kind of
addiction into khan at
everyone's life and
uh especially with with younger people i
i
i really because i i was going through
this when when i was in junior high
uh not because of social media but
because i was in angels in the outfield
i dealt with like the kind of self-doubt
and questions of like do people really
like me for me or do they like me
because i was in this movie and how can
i know
if i'm really worth anything or if if
it's all about these appearances and
like
is is there any me there at all if i
stop doing these appearances like
will everyone like you know forget about
me turn on me etc exactly and so and
and that was that made junior high like
it was it made it angst written for me
and of course
junior high's angst written for
everybody for lots of reasons but
i don't know i i i am i when i see
especially younger people
experiencing some of the same kind of
addiction to
fame and attention that i think like
people in hollywood have experienced for
generations now
it worries me it makes me feel like we
should be worried
you know yeah like you have teenage kids
like you know having
like their entire high school class like
following them into their bedroom like
you know on their smartphone or whatever
i mean like you know
like that that's a very intense
experience that yeah that
previously started thinking of yourself
differently if
you are a performance and there's no
boundary there then like the most
important thing in life i think
especially as a younger person but it's
something i
still very much believe in as a you know
dad now
you have to have your own like
your own relationship with yourself
you have to have that space where you
are you and you know who you
are and you are who you are because of
your own preferences and your own
feelings and your own beliefs
and if that goes away because you're
you're
constantly offered opportunities to
present a performance version of
yourself and get the dopamine hits that
you get when people
you know hit the heart button and like
you or retweet you or whatever
it you it's it's easy to lose
track of that core relationship that you
have
with yourself it's and it's you gotta
spend time
alone you have to spend time just
going deep down into yourself and
ignoring what
anybody says because ultimately
yeah as kurt cobain says all we are is
all alone or all alone is all we are
you ultimately you're the only you are
the only one and everybody else no
matter how close you get and like i feel
deeply deeply close with like my family
but
it's there there is no matter what
there's a difference between
that relationship you have inside your
own
head and it's precious and it's it's a
part of what makes us human and it's
loseable
it's so losable if you never spend any
time on it if you spend
all your time for others presenting
yourself
to others wow man that's really profound
and deep and correct
uh you know i mean i've just i mean i've
just gotten like a
glimpse of it myself uh yeah i fear for
what we're doing to a lot of these kids
brains
um and sense of self uh because i
certainly never felt
that visible and on display when i was
um
a kid you know it's like i was a shy uh
bookworm and
you know go home close the door and read
my fantasy novel or whatever
yeah yeah that's important i did that
too
and you asked like how come i'm like not
addicted to drugs or
or you know in jail or something like
unfortunately a certain number of kids
who experience fame
are i think a lot of it is because i was
encouraged and did have time to just
like be by myself and read that fantasy
novel and
like just have that time with myself and
not not just
be always obsessed with what do other
people think of me how can i present
myself to more and more people and what
should that presentation be and
um it gets convoluted so much with art
too that's the other thing i
i i well that's something about art man
and like i've experienced something like
this even um so i'm trying to get
universal basic income across the finish
line
and one of the things that happened on
the campaign trail and like and that you
can relate to this is that like people
uh people need a person to like pin it
on
you know so it's like if i want this
thing to happen then it's going to have
to be
me like making the case talking to
people
saying hey we should really do this and
there's like this continued projection
outward
you know that that like that you have to
do and not to say i'm like i'm not like
an artist or creative in the same way
but like
i there are some parallels because like
you have to continuously like project
this energy out uh and
like it and like th this with the
struggle you're describing and
creativity go hand in hand because like
sometimes you
like there are creatives who are like
look i just like my work to speak for
itself
but unfortunately like just no one
operates that way
not as much these days yeah thank you
for listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you